public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
julien de normandie secrétaire d'état
chargé de la cohésion des territoires
est l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation de public sénat avec
les échos radio classique et la fp
représenter ce soir par lucile bréau et
jérémy marc au bon soir à tous deux
trois grandes questions pour vous
premièrement va la première elle
s'adresse à vous mais également au
principal intéressé comment corriger
l'image d' emmanuel macron puisque notre
sondage opinionway montre une attentes
insatisfaites de justice sociale
deuxième question est ce que vous
promettez un choc de construction 1 pour
remédier à la crise du logement à la
laquelle veut s'attaquer votre loi enfin
troisième question vous qui étiez à
l'origine avec d'autres il y a deux ans
maintenant dans marché ce que vous
confirmez la pression d'un parti
présidentiel qui manque d'élan sans jeu
de mots puisque ces deux noms de votre
loi sur le logement
en tous les cas d'un parti qui peine à
exister mais d'abord je viens de
normandie une toute première question
d'actualité ou plutôt l'image du jour
[Musique]
l'image du jour c'est celle du héros
mamoudou gassama ce jeune malien sans
papiers qui a donc sauvé d'une façon
héroïque
cet enfant de 4 ans qui était suspendu
dans le vide à paris d'abord les images
vous en toucher comme nous tous je pense
que j'ai réagit absolument comme tous
les français à la vision de ces images
effectivement c'est un véritable héros
je crois que ce qui est le plus beau
dans son geste c'est qu'on a le
sentiment qu'il ne réfléchit pas une
seconde qui va directement sauver cet
enfant et je crois moi en tant que père
de quatre enfants avec des enfants de
cet âge là que effectivement c'est un
héros et on ressent beaucoup
d'admiration faso à la fois au courage
et à la volonté de ce nouvel héros alors
effectivement et donc que le chef de
l'état l'a reçu aussitôt enfin ce matin
il lui annoncer sa naturalisation donc
exactement les papiers c'est la bravoure
récompensés je trouve que le président
de la république a eu une très belle
expression il a indiqué que la france
était une volonté est que ce héros avait
montré cette volonté et je pense qu'il a
parfaitement résumé le fait que on lui
octroie cette naturalisation qu'on va
nous permettre également de rentrer au
niveau des sapeurs pompiers de paris et
je trouve que c'est non seulement juste
récompense mais surtout que c'est
effectivement le témoin de de cette
volonté avec cet acte héroïque et cette
menace d'actes héroïques évidemment de
tous les sans papiers mais au minimum
vous leur demandez une volonté non je
pense qu'il faut vraiment tout
différencier ne partons pas sur la
politique
migros a migratoires lorsqu'il s'agit de
saluer un acte encore une fois héroïque
mais je trouve que le le président de la
république en en témoignant de cette
volonté que la france est une volonté je
le pense profondément la france est est
aussi une volonté et je trouve que c'est
un bien bel hommage qui l'a rendu à cet
égard est pas une volonté aussi
peut-être de l'exécutif de montreux
le visage plein d'humanité après les
débats et les contestations au sujet de
la loi d'immigration non non mais vous
savez cette humanité on pourra en
reparler dans le détail la politique
migratoire qui a été maître pendant des
décennies qui visait surtout à se dire
avec un comportement sur notre
territoire national on arrivera
peut-être à convaincre certains micro de
ne pas venir sur le territoire national
je pense que cette politique là n'était
pas la bonne et que la politique que
nous sommes en train de mener avec le
ministre de l'intérieur qui vise à
raccourcir les délais au bout desquels
on peut dire à des personnes en
situation de demandeur d'asile par
exemple que oui ou non ils auront ce
statut de réfugié c'est rendre beaucoup
plus humaine justement cette politique
migratoire et donc moi je j'assume
pleinement et j'ai je revendique le fait
que cette politique migratoire nouvelles
avec des délais reserré avec l'humain
remis au centre de tout va dans le bon
sens allez je la première question que
je vous annonçais va vous être posée
maintenant par lucile bréau
[Musique]
je suis et la première question comment
corriger julien de normandie l'image d'
emmanuel macron alors que michel le
disait on à un sondage pour l'épreuve de
vérité qui montre qu'il ya encore du
chemin à faire
oui le sondage effectivement le voici
pour 53% des français aujourd'hui je
viens de normandie les inégalités et
biens ont augmenté depuis l'élection du
président de la république donc si
l'objectif c'est de les réduire là c'est
raté ça il faut toujours partir de la
perception des français toujours et je
suis le premier à le dire dans la mesure
où y compris le projet présidentiel que
nous avons conçu et partie de cette
perception des français on avait
organisé une grande marche l'époque à
l'époque qui avait fait beaucoup parler
après c'est moi je suis en charge d'un
ministère qui s'appelle la cohésion des
territoires
si on l'appeler autrement ce serait la
lutte contre toutes les fractures
parce que la plus grande des inégalités
qu'on a en france la plus grande c'est
l'inégalité destin c'est le fait que
vous n'ayez pas les mêmes chances de
réussite en fonction du territoire où
vous êtes
et alors la perception vous l'avez
rappelé elle est là le travail que je
fais avec jacques mézard avec l'ensemble
du gouvernement
je peux vous dire qu'il est plein entier
et intense on a déjà mis en place des
vrais des vraies luttes contre des
fractures territoriales
la fracture sur le numérique la fracture
sur l'école dans les quartiers les plus
difficiles
la fracture sur des zones où la sécurité
n'était pas suffisante il faut continuer
donc on va continuer à prendre des
mesures fortes
il faut toujours aller dans ce sens là
mais moi je peux vous le dire mon boulot
en tant que secrétaire d'état à la
cohésion des territoires
ça se résume à lutter contre ces
fractures territoriales
mais comment vous expliquez que ce
constat continue d'exister un an après
on a l'impression que c'est toujours les
mêmes questions qui reviennent qui est
un besoin de justice sociale qui n'est
pas avec cette image négative est
accolée malgré le
le bilan d'un an que vous présentez
aujourd'hui parce que fondamentalement
s'est fracturé exercice elle n'existe
pas depuis un an
fondamentalement s'est fracturé ça fait
des décennies un autre exemple très
concret avec jacques mézard on a lancé
une formidable opération de
revitalisation des coeurs de ville de ce
qu'on appelle les villes secondaires
vous savez les villes à quelques
dizaines de milliers d'habitants pendant
des années ces villes et on en connaît
tous parfois nous en venons ces villes
pendant des années ont été les parents
pauvres des politiques d'aménagement
aujourd'hui on met 5 milliards d'euros
sur la durée du quinquennat pour aller
les revitaliser pour redonner vie au
commerce à l'intérieur pour rénover les
logements cela ça ça se met en place
on est en train de signer les premiers
contrats de revitalisation ça prendra le
temps nécessaire mais ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que cette ce sentiment
sa perception d'inégalités elle est
profondément ancrée chez certains ont
tenté de perturber manuel manuela but
est beau c'est alors la perception des
manuels macron il faut aussi appeler un
chat un chat
vous avez des oppositions qui agitent
des juifs ou des chiffons rouges en
disant par 6 2 6 ou là que nous serions
tantôt le président de tels types de
populations résidant des restos d'autres
hélas il faut pareil il faut prendre
pied à pied prend un point tous les
sujets de critiques qui nous sont
opposés prenez par exemple et je trouve
ça fabuleux la taxe d'habitation les
oppositions qui aujourd'hui sont en
train de nous dire vous faites une
politique en faveur des villes et pas en
faveur des territoires
ils n'ont pas voté la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation l'impôt le plus
injuste territorialement propre parlant
c'est la taxe d'habitation dont vous
voyez également là l'incohérence des
discours de ces oppositions qui m a
essayé d' agiter ces chiffres vous
disiez président des riches président
trop urbain aussi l'opposition de droite
martèle sur l'angle d'attac de la
supposée déconnexion de l'exécutif avec
les territoires
vous avez énuméré quelques mesures pour
les territoires justement et pourtant
l'impression que ça imprime pas que vous
avez du mal à remettre en cohérence
toutes ces mesures là comment vous
l'expliquez mais il faut expliquer je
suis ravi que vous m'invitez pourquoi
justement poursuivre ce travail
d'explication et donc effectivement on a
pris des mesures très fortes songez par
exemple la téléphonie
on a signé un accord historique 3
milliards d'euros investis par les
opérateurs pour mettre fin aux zones
blanches sur notre territoire
ça fait des décennies là aussi qu'on
nous le qu'on nous le promet la taxe
d'habitation on en a parlé le
dédoublement des classes d'écoles dans
les zones les plus défavorisées
donc on prend toutes ces mesures le
ministre blanc caire aujourd'hui à ces
deux nouvelles annoncé de nouvelles
mesures en faveur des filières de
refaire tout le débat sur la politique
finale mais c'est ce qu'on vous oppose
évidemment oui parce que j'étais en fait
le alors le procès d opposition elles
sont dans leur rôle
mais encore une fois quand je vois
qu'elles n'ont pas voté la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation d'habitation je
les renvoie vers leurs incohérences et
je pense que nous n'avons aucune leçon
je dis bien aucune leçon à recevoir de
ces personnes là après la perception des
français elle est là et cette perception
des français
c'est ce qui va guider notre action
c'est ce qui guide notre action du 1er
au premier jour et ce qui va continuer à
guider notre action jusqu'au dernier
jour pourquoi pas ce que c'est il n'y a
aucune fatalité aucune cette principale
inégalités en france qui l'inégalité de
destin vous rendez compte ça veut dire
que la république n'est pas la même pour
tous
cette inégalité de destin - mon
ministère enfin c'est le ministère de
buts contre ces inégalités
donc on ira jusqu'au alors vous dites
vous êtes le ministre effectivement des
territoires est ce que quand on vous dit
la limitation à 80 km/heure sur
certaines routes nationales mais aussi
comme le ministre d'intérieur jeu
sûrement joker parce que c'est très mal
perçu non moi je l'assumé mais je
l'assumé totalement mais pourquoi je
l'assumé parce que vous savez il faut
savoir prendre des mesures parfois
impopulaires
pourquoi on le prend cette mesure
absolument pas pour embêter les français
absolument pas on le prend parce que
aujourd'hui vous avez encore des
milliers de personnes qui chaque année
meurent sur les routes
et puis après vous savez et le président
de la république l'a rappelé d'ailleurs
nous on agit avec méthode et la méthode
c'est quoi c'est qu'on part d'un
problème le problème
insoutenable en français ce nombre de
personnes décédées d'accord sur les
routes on prend des mesures fortes
la limitation et puis on va évaluer on
évaluera dans deux ans pour savoir si
maintien ou non ça marche encore et puis
on avisera pas de joker
autre rare que l'on sait peut-être
l'occasion de parler de ces déclarations
de ce week-end il a évoqué
bon les termes sont formels la
complicité des manifestants qui étaient
dans la rue ce week-end entre autres
avec les casseurs qu'on a vu le 1er mai
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est adapté
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec lui
que j'ai cité des manifestants je pense
qu'il faut il faut là aussi c'est c'est
trop facile de sortir tel de telles
bulles phrase faut le remettre dans le
contexte où il doit rencontrer tous dans
une société de la vigilance dans une
société c'est très vrai pour la sécurité
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que chacun peut participer
en identifiant en allant avertir en
prenant ses responsabilités quand vous
êtes hommes politiques pour faire en
sorte que demain il n'y a pas il n'y ait
pas la possibilité d'avoir ces black
blocks qui n'ont rien à voir avec les
manifestants et quand vous êtes en pli
site et quand vous êtes un manifestant
ou vous même vous avez la possibilité là
aussi de participer
quand vous voyez des personnes à les
prévenir un tel monde et concrètement
north calotte pour moi c'est cette
société de vigilance c'est de dire que
là aussi la vie en société
c'est la vie on a tous et tous la
possibilité de participer à cet effort
collectif et s'agissant de la sécurité
s'agissant de la prévention on a toutes
et tous la possibilité d'agir là où nous
nous trouvons quand vous êtes
manifestants quand vous êtes un élu
local quand vous êtes membre des nations
c'est à dire quand on est revenu avec en
tête de cortège le black box vous pouvez
effectivement allé avertir quand vous
voyez télé n'y a personne qui parce
qu'on connaît bien leurs techniques ils
arrivent ils sont pas habillées en black
blocks et puis tout d'un coup me sens
mais on vous les identifier à les forces
de l'ordre elle est prévenue en défense
lorsque des forces de repérer aussi
séparés mais bien entendu mais là c'est
absolument pas ça que dit gérard collomb
pense que il ya bien un reproche qu'on
ne peut pas faire à gérard collomb c'est
de ne pas être fermes pour lutter sans
relâche en mettant tous les moyens de
police nécessaires pour faire en sorte
que ces individus ne puisse agir
il est pour faire en sorte que tous ceux
qui souhaitent manifester puisse le
faire dans le calme en aucun cas gérard
collomb dit que ce n'est pas le boulot
des forces de l'ordre bien au contraire
c'est le boulot des forces de l'ordre
après une société de vigilance moi je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui donc
il est tout à fait bien et justifiée
puisque la complicité en faites vous
éplorée la passivité des manifestants je
déplore rien je dis juste que lorsque
l'angle de vigilance non je dis juste
que quand nous vivons en société nous
avons tous là où nous agissons là nous
vivons en fonction de nos métiers de nos
fonctions nous avons tous la possibilité
de participer à notre vie en société
une image qui a marqué les esprits lors
de la marée humaine qui était annoncé
samedi c'est celle de d'emmanuel macron
dans un uniforme nazi comment est ce que
vous avez reçu cette image mais tu as
grandi dans les rues ces images alors
que ce soit celle là où où que ce soit
celle où nous voyons emmanuel macron son
effigie brûlés sont totalement
inqualifiable et insupportable mais je
pense que là aussi dans les manifestants
vous avez deux types de manifestants
vous avez ceux qui revendiquent qui
portent des propositions qui sont en
désaccord mais qui essaye de faire
avancer le débat
et puis vous en avez d'autres qui ont
des propos des propos que moi je trouve
antidémocratique
des propos qui ne vise qu'à une chose
c'est de refaire le match c'est à dire
de revenir sur des résultats de
l'élection présidentielle
la seule et vraie marée populaire pour
reprendre le terme de ce week-end c'est
l'élection présidentielle moi quand
j'entends un jean luc mélenchon
mélenchon appeler une révolution
populaire
un franc bonheur aussi et oui mais je
prends ce terme de révolution là je dis
à jean luc mélenchon mais le soir du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle les français n'ont pas
choisi votre programme est donc arrêté
de refaire le match
à chaque fois respecter le vote des
français
on peut être contre il soyons contre de
manière constructive avec des
propositions et non pas dans ses
postures parce que quand il s'agit
d'être démocrate il faut l'être
tous les jours on n'est pas démocrate
quand ça nous arrange parce que le vote
des français est allé dans son sens je
sais vous revendiquez toujours ce
positionnement ni droite ni gauche qui a
fait d'une certaine manière le succès et
la force des manuels macron quand on à
jean françois copé qui était sur ce
plateau il ya quand même trois semaines
de ça et qui dit mais c'est un président
de droite
il fait ce que nous on n'a pas eu le
courage de faire
comment vous vous positionnez visé moi
je moi je le revendique d'autant plus
que vous savez mon engagement politique
il sait il est né de cela mon engagement
mon combat il vient d'année ou emmanuel
macron n'était pas candidat emmanuel
macron était ministre de l'économie
où j'ai eu à à mener des réformes avec
lui et on voyait cette opposition
stérile entre la droite et la gauche et
donc moi je suis profondément convaincu
que cette nouvelle offre politique qui
est la république en marche
elle est fondée sur des positions qui
sont dites centrale c'est-à-dire qu'on
ne cherche pas à savoir si ces de droite
ou de gauche
on cherche à faire en sorte que ce soit
bon pour le pays et ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire remettre de travail au centre
ça veut dire créer de l'émancipation par
tout ça veut dire faire en sorte qu'on
puisse en finir avec ces inégalités
ça prendra du temps mais on va tout
donner pour pouvoir en finir donc oui
moi je le revendique cette position ni
de droite ni de gauche
cette position sans éclat alors vous
avez beaucoup travaillé ces dernières
semaines avec jean louis borloo qui a
présenté tout à fait en plan banlieues
mais il est assez dépité
même si vous allez nous dire le
contraire écouter ce que propose valérie
pécresse est légalement dépité par
l'absence d'un plan banlieues finalement
elle annonce qu'avec d'autres présidents
de région elle va mettre sur pied son
propre programme et elle met en garde le
chef de l'état après ses propos sur les
mâles blancs
j'ai été profondément choqué par le
propos du président de la république sur
les mâles blancs qui ne peuvent pas
parler les banlieues pourquoi parce que
d'abord c'est un des légitimes la parole
des politiques
je suis une femelle blanche et je
revendique d'avoir installé le conseil
régional en banlieue de m'être installé
en banlieue et d'avoir quelque chose à
dire sur l'avenir de ces banlieues de
ces quartiers populaires
aujourd'hui il ne faut pas ouvrir la
porte communautarisme le communautarisme
est une gangrène de la société française
racialisées le propos politique
pour moi c'est plus qu'une erreur c'est
dangereux c'est dangereux pour l'avenir
est-ce que vous ouvrez la porte au
communautarisme
non pas du tout mais je pense que madame
pécresse n'a pas compris ce que le
président de la république ou n'a pas
écouté ce que l'ensemble du discours du
président de la république
qu'est ce qui dit il s'agit pas du tout
de se dire que la politique des
quartiers ne peut pas être refait par un
mâle blanc moi je revendique totalement
légitime
j'y passe des heures et des heures des
marées blanc depuis un an et jusqu'à
preuve du contraire je suis
effectivement un mâle blanc ce que dit
président de la république c'est qu'il
ne faut pas se cantonner à deux
personnes
il ne faut pas ce qu'on tenait
simplement un pouvoir politique qui
décideraient sur la base de propositions
ce qui est bon ou pas il faut le faire
ensemble il faut le faire
son appel vous savez de manière
horizontale et ça veut dire quoi
concrètement ça veut dire que pour
rétablir les bonnes mesures pour faire
en sorte que les choses changent
véritablement eh bien il faut le faire
avec les habitants avec toutes les
associations avec tous les élus locaux
avec le pouvoir politique
in fine et mais il faut le faire de
manière globale et ne pas se cantonner
c'est ça l'unique message quand quand on
parle de communautarisme est un reproche
aussi qui revient souvent liée à la
personnalité de yassine belattar qui a
fait beaucoup de plateau ces derniers
temps qui a aussi beaucoup croisé le fer
avec des humoristes 1 et un humour y ont
versé controversé par certains et qui
travaillent avec vous qui semble-t-il a
quand même beaucoup travailler avec vous
qui a présenté en tout cas fait le stand
up du plan banlieues à l'elysée la
semaine dernière est ce qu'il est tout à
fait dans la juste mesure est ce qu'il
est tout à fait dans son rôle yassine
belattar dans les propos qu'il tient la
manière dont ils se positionnent mais au
fait là aussi le sujet rechange mais
j'assume totalement le sous jacent de
votre question vous aurez de se dire
est-ce que c'est plutôt lui plutôt
d'autres
moi je vous savez mon boulot il est
fondamentalement mais fondamentalement
tourner vers une chose il faut faire
bosser tout le monde ensemble et on peut
nous reprocher beaucoup de choses depuis
un an sur la politique de la ville il ya
des jouets ont l'impression mais il ya
une fente en duel justement il ya une
chose à faire il ya une chose qu'on ne
peut pas nous reprocher c'est pas avoir
omis tout autour de la table quel qu'il
soit que ce soit un yassine belattar que
ce soit des associations qui font un
boulot remarquable comme le blues n où
tant d'autres que ce soit avec les élus
locaux et moi mon boulot
moi je suis garant
justement de faire en sorte qu'on me
pose tous dans la même quand vous
entendez mesure c'est important la
dynamique salines encore plus quand vous
entendez yassine belattar dire que
manuel valls est celui qui a le plus de
briser le vivre ensemble vous n'êtes pas
choqué non je vais pas rentrer non mais
je vais pas rentrer dans les rangs on
connaît les relations entre les deux
personnes depuis maintenant à un nombre
mois donc encore une fois moi je veux
avoir un discours d'apaisement ce que je
fais c'est que je bosse avec tout le
monde parce que les mesures c'est
important
la dynamique elle est encore plus
importante que que tout le reste
pourquoi parce que chacun peut avec sa
sensibilité avec ses positions après que
tout le monde sauf que la cour n'en ait
une otarie sts mais sauf évidemment les
mouvements qui ne sont pas soit
républicain soit qu'ils prêchent ou
prône des valeurs qui ne sont pas les
nôtres mais au-delà de cela il faut
faire bosser tout le monde ensemble
allez on arrive à la deuxième grande
question de cette émission julien de
normandie et c'est jérémy marraud qui va
vous la poser
[Musique]
alors votre projet de loi élan arrive
dans l'hémicycle dans la salle à
l'assemblée nationale cette semaine
vous promettez un choc d'offre un choc
de la construction quel en est l'intérêt
alors qu'on a vu en 2017
avec plus de 400 mille logements
construits on était déjà sur des plus
hauts quasiment historique parce que moi
je
j'ai une conviction c'est que
aujourd'hui il ya pas une et pas un
problème de logement et un très grave
problème de logement en france qu
effectivement vous l'avez dit vous avez
raison il ya plus de 400 mille logements
presque 500 mille demandes de permis de
construire qui ont été formulées et fait
l'année dernière c'est autant qu'au
début des années 80 et depuis vous avez
12 millions de français et beaucoup de
familles qui divorce et donc il y a un
manque très fort de logements en france
et aujourd'hui pour construire des
logements vous avez par exemple pour ne
prendre que celui à un code de la
construction qui fait 2300 pages qui est
plus gros que le code civil ou plus gros
que le code du travail
un code de la construction qui est
totalement prescripteurs qui vous dit
exactement ce que vous devez faire dans
les moindres détails
bref vous avez un système qui est figé
et moi l'un des points dont je suis le
plus fier dans cette loi dont l'examen
débute mercredi
c'est que avec plus de 60 articles on ne
rajoute pas d'obligation au contraire on
libère on fait en sorte que demain il
soit plus facile de construire plus
facile de libérer des terrains plus
facile de laisser libre par à
l'innovation
bref on prendre des mesures fortes pour
faire en sorte que demain on construise
plus mieux et moins cher
ce projet de loi il est une gestation
parfois un petit peu douloureuse et
notamment avec les bailleurs sociaux
qu'elles sont comment sortir de cette
logique de rapport de force avec les
bailleurs sociaux quelles sont vos
relations actuellement avec le en fait
les bailleurs sociaux
on a toujours beaucoup travaillé avec
eux y compris lorsque nous avons eu des
moments difficiles qu'on avait réduit
les apl et elle traduit pour eux par une
baisse du chiffre d'affaires évidemment
les loyers il s'avère que les appels
sont directement versées aux bailleurs
sociaux effectivement sauf que toute la
discussion ait toute la réforme que nous
portons c'est de dire aux bailleurs
sociaux
on va réduire les subventions à la
sortie parce qu'en contrepartie et ça
personne n'en parle parce qu'en
contrepartie on augmente
considérablement les aide à l'entrée
c'est à dire les aides
la construction parce que c'est quoi la
bonne méthode aujourd'hui en termes
d'appui de l'état pour le secteur de la
construction
c'est d'aider là où on construit d'aidé
là on rénove en gros de faire plus
d'eads à la construction plutôt que des
subventions à la sortie c'est en fait
quelque chose qui avait été mis en place
par raymond barre des 40 ans ou raymond
barre à l'époque c'est à dire on va
faire plus de subventions à la sortie
que dell à la construction en amont ben
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui cela est une
erreur et donc on inverse la loge à
grimper nous le budget qu'elle consacre
l'état c'est plus de quarante mille 40
milliards da l'eurocité le thème de la
deuxième question ou de notre sondage
opinionway et 64% des français donc une
forte majorité considère que l'état
consacre assez d'argent pour le logement
mais qu'il est mal utilisé donc oui
l'exemple l'exemple que j'ai un accord
est l'exemple que je viens de vous
donner vous montre qu'on peut faire
mieux on peut faire mieux parce qu'on
s'y que 40 milliards d'euros on peut là
se demander est-ce qu'il faut pas plus
les investir pour justement favoriser la
construction du toit rigide en ont le
plus le sénateur et l'ère philippe
dallier et qui est l'une
seine-saint-denis considère lui que vous
allez faire plus mal on les côtés vous
réagissez va changer le modèle
économique du logement social
on va demander aux prix vient
d'intervenir on va chercher de la
rentabilité et de la rentabilité dans le
logement social qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
la rentabilité s'est pas à 30 ans ou à
40 ans sur le modèle actuel il va
vouloir de la rentabilité à 10 ans à 15
ans et donc on risque de concentrer les
populations les plus pauvres parce qu'il
va falloir vendre à tout prix des
logements sociaux et donc on va rentrer
dans une mécanique qui n'est plus du
tout celle que nous avons connue qui
n'était peut-être pas parfaite mais qui
avait aussi pour vocation d'assurer un
minimum de mixité sociale et j'ai
vraiment l'impression au travers de la
loi de finances et du texte est lent et
bien on va s'en éloigner et moi je tire
la sonnette d'alarmé lourde
oui alors il s'avère qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé avec le sénateur d'allier
parce que ce texte a fait l'objet d'un
parcours assez singulier puisque on a
pendant de longs mois fait ce qu'on
appelait une conférence de consensus
dès qu'on a réuni tous les épaules
toutes les a cédés à l'arrivée gris et
on avait travaillé avec eux
suis pas du tout en accord avec ce que
vient de dire le sénateur d'allier le
sénateur d'allier ne précise pas que
pour accompagner cette transformation du
logement social qui est nécessaire il
songe est aujourd'hui qu'il ya près de
deux millions de personnes qui sont en
attente d'un logement social pour qu'est
ce qu'on fait on reste dans le statu quo
ont fait rien et on se dit peut-être que
dans 20 ans 30 ans 40 ans c'est deux
millions de personnes auront eu une
offre de logement social non on essaye
de faire mieux on crée une honte
transforme le modèle mais on le fait de
manière totalement responsable c'est à
dire que pour accompagner ces bailleurs
sociaux pour les accompagner on met en
face des investissements qui sont très
importants on leur permet d'avoir accès
à ce qu'on appelle les financements de
la caisse des dépôts de manière
totalement nouvelle
chose qu'il n'avait pas eu jusqu'à
présent on rénove même le livret à qui
est l'une des sources de financement de
ces bailleurs sociaux
bref on fait en sorte de pouvoir les
accompagner dans cette production
et que faire des locataires qui
apportait de la mixité sociale
finalement ou en payant un surloyer et
qui continue à occuper leur logement
social et sur le redis il est temps de
partir non moi je pense que la mixité
sociale elle était essentielle et vous
savez le dans le logement social en fait
vous avez énormément de type de
logements qui sont différents donc on
est vraiment très attachés à cette
mixité sociale et notamment on travaille
beaucoup en amont du passage de la loi
avec des députés comme le député
stéphane peu ou françois pupponi pour
justement préserver sa dérision si parti
social qui a pour l'essentiel d'un pour
cent des locataires de la iveme
dépassent les plafonds de ressources
est-ce qu'ils doivent partir il ya un
sujet qui est essentiel c'est ce qu'on
appelle la mobilité au sein du parc
social et la vraie mobilité pendant des
années on s'est dit justement faut faire
partir ces personnes à l est pas là la
vraie mobilité la vraie mobilité c'est
ce qu'on appelle la sous-occupation vous
allez beaucoup de personnes qui passent
que leurs enfants ont quitté le domicile
ont une chambre vide parfois deux
chambres vides et donc nous ce qu'on
fait par la loi ce qu'on va faire ce
qu'on a proposé aux parlementaires
c'est à dire tous les six ans les
bailleurs sociaux devront proposer je
dis bien proposer à leurs lots mer un
logement qu'il soit véritablement adapté
à leurs besoins
et pourquoi c'est intéressant parce que
ça veut dire que le f4 le cas pièce où
vous n'avez besoin en fait vous en tant
que locataire qu un deux pièces
vous pouvez leur donner des familles qui
en ont besoin et inversement vous votre
deux pièces vous paierez moins cher que
votre 4 pièces bref tout le monde est
gagnant et moi je pense que le vrai
débat sur la mobilité
il est là il est sur cette mobilité à
l'intérieur les logements sous-occupés
le sud alors il ya il ya un autre sujet
qui suscite beaucoup d'inquiétudes et de
critiques et les écologistes entre
autres sans s'en empare c'est la
question de la loi littoral est ce que
dans votre loi il ya un risque
finalement de revenir à une possibilité
de tout bétonner
regardez c'était là une de var matin
aujourd'hui même nom voilà il ya des
inquiétudes
qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire pour
rassurer aujourd'hui un mélange personne
je vais très très très claire la loi
littoral c'est 1 1 acquis qu'il ne faut
absolument pas remettre en cause
absolument pas donc je vais être très
claire la loi littoral il faut garder
toute son ambition et je le dis avec
d'autant plus de conviction vous savez
moi je suis ingénieur agronome
fertilisation des sols je connais et je
vois bien tout l'intérêt et il la loi
littoral bah oui mais a quand même
certains les écologistes de monter au
créneau et 10 non vous allez me remettre
des choses qui ne sont pas autorisés
aujourd'hui j'ai ce qu'est ce que le
débat en commission la semaine dernière
a permis a permis de faire ce qu'on
appelle au sein d'une zone déjà habité
vous avez ce qu'on appelle des dents
creuses c'est à dire qu'entre deux
habitations
vous avez quelque chose qui n'est pas
habité et donc ce que permet la loi
c'est de pouvoir dire un au sein de
cette continuer continuité entre ces
deux habitations
quand vous avez une dent creuse il
pourra être demain possible d'y faire
une habitation et voyez vous n'êtes
absolument pas dans une remise en cause
de la loi littoral ni de près ni de loin
et surtout pas sur la bande des 100
mètres ça et qui est l'un des principaux
axes de la loi littoral dont je vais
être très rassurant sur ce point jérémy
rassurant aussi pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
on sait que le projet de loi prévoit
d'assouplir les normes en la matière en
créant des logements qu'on appelle
évolutif et là encore les associations
disent attention on remet en cause
l'accessibilité maintenant défenseur des
droits le web que j'ai reçus en club que
j'ai reçu encore vendredi dernier je me
permets de vous corriger sur un point il
ne s'agit pas de remettre en cause les
normes des personnes en situation de
handicap
je peux vous dire que j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup travaillé avec elle sur ce
sujet il s'agit de changer un tout petit
peu de logique en disant aujourd'hui
quand vous construisez un immeuble neuf
vous avez 100% de vos logements qui
seront adaptés c'est à dire que toutes
les pièces sont adaptés des personnes à
mobilité réduite en chaise roulante et
demain on va faire des logements dits
évolutif c'est à dire que ces logements
seront vous accompagneront au fur et à
mesure de votre vie dit autrement la
salle de bains qui aujourd'hui peut
représenter quasiment la taille de votre
chambre
quand vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir une
salle de bains type adaptés aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
on vous dit ben temps vous n'en avez pas
besoin vous prenez une salle de bains
normal mais le jour vous en avez besoin
on a d'ores et déjà conçu l'appartement
pour n'avoir qu'à faire de très faible
transformation pour l'adapter et c'est
juste une logique qui est un tout
si peu différent qui est de se dire en
rien on diminue les acquis en termes de
normes de personnes en situation de
handicap mais en revanche on fait en
sorte que l'appartement accompagne les
individus évidemment le coût de la
construction c'est pas le coup c'est la
bataille c'est la taille
j insiste beaucoup en gros un
appartement de 65 m² la salle de bain si
aujourd'hui vous dit
tant que vous n'en avez pas besoin vous
l'a laissée à la taille normale ça vous
permet de gagner jusqu'à 25 mètres
carrés alors et donc d'avoir une chambre
plus grande pour vous en ferez la
normandie vous avez bien sûr défendu
tout à l'heure la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation mais certains observateurs
de l'immobilier s'inquiètant 10 juin
mais ça va avoir un facteur
inflationniste sur les loyers parce
qu'il ya des propriétaires qui vendirent
bas puisque vous gagnez là où on va
peut-être j'ai peut-être récupérer une
partie du gain est ce que vous avez
observé ça de près ce que vous sentez
cette menace vous évidemment qu'on va
tout
évidemment qu'on va tous nous servait de
près non moi je ne
je pense que à un moment donné il faut
arrêter à chaque fois qu'on prend des
décisions et des bonne décision d'ouvrir
des boîtes à fantasmes présent à chaque
fois il y aura un effet pervers ou non
c'est quoi le premier avec la taxe
d'habitation c'est que c'est l'un des
impôts les plus injustes
voir le lien je le dis et donc au bout
d'un moment on prend nos responsabilités
et aux accords cette intro sport alors
il faut le supprimer aussi sur les
résidences secondaires on a vu
christophe castaner prendre position là
dessus et dire oui
moi à titre personnel je suis pour le
maintenir cet impôt sur les résidences
secondaires et ses relais le travail
christophe carré alors c'est ce n'est
pas dans mon champ de mariage mis
d'accord avec christiane multiplication
il est au service de la sous-direction
tester la neige vont aboutir à une
politique pour les riches propriétaires
de résidences secondaires la fiscalité
locale c'est une fiscalité que nous
sommes en train de revoir pour faire à
la fin un meilleur équilibre au bénéfice
de tous les français qui habite partout
sur le territoire et pourquoi vous y
être favorable à ce moment là pour
autistes et san juan pour les raisons
que le matériel hors augmentation est ce
que parce que fondamentalement qu'est ce
qu'on cherche à pourquoi on a supprimé
la taxe d'habitation
parce que c'est un impôt qui est injuste
c'est à dire que lorsque vous êtes tous
pareils dans des dents les mêmes niveaux
de revenus dans les mêmes emplois mais
juste vous êtes à deux parties
différentes du territoire vous parfois
payer beaucoup plus de taxe d'habitation
alors que vous êtes dans un territoire
plus pauvre que vous ne payez par
exemple au coeur de paris et donc c'est
une injustice sur le volet secondaire
c'est un peu différent voyez que cette
injustice
elle ne peut pas elle n'est pas sur la
même base de comparaison vous n'êtes pas
en train de comparer deux citoyens l'un
à l'autre alors vous avez peut-être me
dire que ça n'est pas dans votre domaine
de compétences mais ce que vous seriez
favorable à l'augmentation des droits de
mutation si la réclamer de frais de
notaire que l'on verse quand on achète
un bien immobilier il est jean l'heure
je pense qu'il faut faire très attention
sur tous ces sujets là pourquoi parce
que on a une politique globale qui est
une politique de lutte contre
l'assignation à résidence l'assignation
à résidence ça veut dire quoi c'est à
dire il faut permettre le plus de
mobilité à tous les français et donc
tous les impôts les taxes qui
peuvent complexifier cette mobilité il
faut il faut y faire attention et donc
les risques et effectivement ça serait
de limiter les transactions immobilières
que je veux dire par là limiter la
mobilité ce que moi j'ai une gêne mais
fondamentalement mais ma conviction
c'est que les politiques la politique de
ce gouvernement
pour être tout entière est retourné vers
la lutte contre la sinisation à
résidence
c'est à dire favoriser les mobilités
encore une fois tout ce débat sur la
fiscalité locale c'est un peu trop
facile de le prendre
fiscalité par fils éric vous voyez bien
c'est aujourd'hui une somme de
différentes fiscalement au dessus il
faut être docteur en 6 qualité
d'ailleurs aimé prendre à vous écouter
on dit alors ils ces casques ou
d'augmenter l'effet des droits de
mutation fait ce qu'il dit
enfin moi ce que je dis c'est quoi la
politique doit être tournée vers la
lutte contre la sinisation de résidence
parce que la meilleure des protections
pour tous les français un point juste
sur l'obligation faite aux communes
d'avoir un certain quota de logements
sociaux
on a vu énormément de d'amendements lors
du passage de votre projet de loi en
commission visant à remettre en cause ce
quota là est ce que vous pouvez prendre
un engagement et dire oui le
gouvernement tiendra bon et garantir à
20% de logements sociaux mais moi je
suis très au clair la loi sru est une
bonne loi
c'est une loi qui est compliqué c'est
une loi qui a vraiment des contraintes
pour beaucoup de communes mais c'est une
bonne loi parce que c'est la loi qui
nous a permis de faire tant de logements
sociaux en france
et qu'aujourd'hui comme je vous le
disais tout est là il manque entre 1 1
million 8 et 2 millions de logements
sociaux en france
donc il faut garder toute l'ambition de
la loi sru
après que des correctifs ici ou là parce
qu'on se rend compte que pour appliquer
cette fois on a des aberrations doivent
être faites pourquoi pas mais il faut
garder toute l'ambition de la loi on va
passer à la troisième partie de
l'émission quand même une question
qu'est ce que vous dites aux architectes
parce qu'on les entend ils sont
mobilisés contre votre loi en gros ils
disent que vous allez bétonné sans souci
de l'esthétisme des bâtiments c'est
encore une ak lorient ce nom mais c'est
surtout c'est totalement faux je dirais
on nous fait un procès en disant que la
loi va supprimer les architectes d'un
certain nombre de nos jours les
programmes sociaux mais c'est totalement
faux qu'est ce qui est aujourd'hui la
loi la loi elle dit
pour toute habitation d'un de grandes
surfaces on va dire dans les surfaces
importantes vous avez besoin d'un
architecte
on y touche en rien en rien qu'est-ce
qu'on fait par la loi on dit en revanche
la relation entre votre maître d'ouvragé
votre maître d'oeuvre et votre
entreprise cela il faut laisser les
personnes s'articuler les uns avec les
autres
parce que ce qu'on ne dit pas c'est que
la loi aujourd'hui en france elle en va
même jusqu'à dire comment les uns avec
les autres devront interagir donc on a
tous figés pour nous on libère cela mais
les arts les architectes la superbe
boulot à arzon leur classe ils font
amende en oeuvre d'accords une troisième
question de l'émission pour vous et
c'est lucile qui va vous la poser
je suis bien dedans
[Musique]
julien de normandie vous étiez l'un des
tout premiers marcheurs il y a deux ans
un de ceux qui accompagnent emmanuel
macron depuis pour ainsi dire le plus
longtemps en même temps aujourd'hui on a
un peu l'impression d'un parti
présidentiel en marchant perte d'élan
qui a du mal à exister ce que vous
confirmer cette impression est ce que
c'est quelque chose aussi que vous
ressentez qu'il ya encore des réglages à
faire
enfin ça et moi effectivement aux
marchands j étais au premier jour j'ai
vécu en marche lorsque nous étions trois
salariés vingt bénévoles et quelques
centaines d'adhérents
bon aujourd'hui il ya plus de 450 mille
adhérents et on a vu tout ce qui s'est
passé en l'espace d'un peu plus de deux
ans simplement
alors on dit en marche aujourd'hui est
moins dynamique etc
enfin bon médéric les derniers jours on
a organisé une grande marche européenne
c'est des dizaines de milliers de portes
qui ont été frappés par tout le temps en
france pour discuter on a des milliers
d'événements qui se passe chaque semaine
partout en france
donc je peux vous dire que sur le
terrain à chaque fois que je fais un
déplacement je vais voir les marcheurs à
chaque fois parce que je pense que c'est
important de pouvoir garder ce lien et
1,10 à cette envie cette action sur le
terrain elle est toujours aussi forte
après que certains commentateurs se
disent on a l'impression qu'en marche va
pas tarder on va moins bien
ce tremblement jeu sur le terrain aller
sur le terrain vous verrez auprès des
marcheurs dans les actions qu'ils font
dans les propos qu'ils tiennent la même
dynamique la même volonté de poursuivre
ce projet présidentiel
moi je vis un moment est profondément
profondément confiant à dans cette
dynamique dans marche alors on écoute
comme le grand politologue pascal
perrineau qui parle justement
aujourd'hui d'une forme de difficultés
dans marche et la république en marche a
été une réussite je le dire au moment
électoral de la présidentielle et des
législatives
une réussite du mouvement dans aux
parents aux mais au fond ce que ne
réussit pas pour l'instant la république
en marche c'est de créer ce mouvement
d'en bas et c'est un mouvement d'en bas
tout à fait important parce que se
profilent à l'horizon les élections
régionales départementales municipales
or tout mouvement politique même qui se
veut un mouvement politique nouveau ne
peut pas se contenter simplement du
mouvement d'en haut il faut un mouvement
d'en bas à partir des territoires et qui
rencontre le mouvement dans vos et c'est
au fond le grand défi pour la république
en marche dans les mois qui viennent le
défi à relever mais déjà relevé à bout
non mais c'est extraordinaire de se
tromper autant dans l'analyse je connais
pourquoi parce que il s'avère que vous
avez face à vous la personne qui a écrit
les statuts dans marche et les statuts
de la république en marché pour ça qu'on
vous pose la question
le parti tout le parti repose sur un
échelon qui l'échelon local qu'on
appelle les comités locaux
on en a 3500 en france mais ça s'enlise
sans foi dans la traite mais aller sur
le terrain
venez avec moi on va aller voir des
marcheurs sur le terrain venez avec moi
vous verrez tout le parti la république
en marche elle est fondée sur le fait
qu'on a partout en france des comités
locaux avec des marcheurs clia des et
qui font des actions sur le terrain
parce que l'engagement de beaucoup de
marcheurs c'est l'engagement politique
au sens le plus noble du terme c'est de
faire des actions pour une part les
politiques de la ville tout à l'heure il
ya énormément par exemple de comités qui
ont fait des interactions entre un
comité local d'un territoire favoriser
avec un comité local d'un quartier
prioritaire de la ville pour mettre en
relation les jeunes et leur donner des
stages de troisième on a organisé mais
quel parti politique aujourd'hui peut
organiser une grande marche européenne
avec des dizaines de milliers de portes
frapper en espagne six semaines quel
parti politique donc toute notre
structure a été fondée sur cette action
du terrain tout c'est ça qui fait
aujourd'hui l'identité dans leur donnez
moi mais vous décrivez un tableau
idyllique sur le papier mais justement
qu'on tombait sur le terrain on voit que
beaucoup de référents par exemple c'est
à dire les représentants de marche au
niveau départemental son parti ont
quitté parfois désabusés leurs fonctions
parce qu'ils étaient pris en étau entre
des marcheurs qui voulaient leur
autonomie des élus qui voulait asseoir
leur autorité sur leur territoire c'est
une vielle il ya des relations aussi
compliqué au scandale mais attendez vous
avez une structure qu'il ya deux ans à
peine
dans cette structure prenez les
référents départementaux certains sont
devenus députés
d'autres ont mené une campagne
présidentielle avec toute l'énergie que
cela demande
certains peuvent avoir ici ou là des
relations difficiles avec untel et untel
mais quoi de plus normal on a une
structure qui aujourd'hui représente
plus de 400 mille adhérents
quoi de plus normal que d'avoir parfois
des difficultés parfois des clivages
entre certains mais je veux dire c'est
la vie en société
c'est bien normal mais par contre deux
là ont tiré comme conclusion que le
parti de la république en marche le
mouvement la république en marche ne va
pas bien on a pas de dynamique
moi j'en dis moi j'en ai connu un des
moments où on se demandait comment on
trouve un second souffle
comment on fait pour changer d'échelle
comment on fait pour gérer un mouvement
politique avec plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes
j'en ai connu à chaque fois la
république en marche on est sorti encore
plus fort donc je vous le confirme
allons ensemble sur le terrain vous
verrez que cette mini caméra mais c'est
quoi le rôle très concrètement
aujourd'hui dans marche dans l'horizon
qu'on a à présent avec emmanuel macron
qui est quand même très très très actif
c'est quoi le rôle de ce parti c'est
d'impulser des idées nouvelles c'est de
préparer déjà la suite c'est ça qu'on a
un peu de mal à percevoir
mais le rôle de ce mouvement si vous de
ce mouvement mouvement politique
il est essentiel et dont il est il et il
est le fondement même de faire vivre
cette démocratie de faire vivre toutes
celles et ceux qui croient en un projet
politique différent mais il est aussi et
d'être garant de tout la méthode qui est
la nôtre et cette méthode c'est pour ça
que je dis que le politologue se trompe
tout à l'heure cette méthode c'est quoi
ça a toujours été de partir justement la
perception des français de partir des
blocages qui sont inhérents je vous
donne un exemple une paire concret
politique de la ville toujours là où on
met en place des emplois francs 16
emplois francs d'autres ont essayé nous
on est parti de ce que nous disaient
tous les gens du terrain ce que fait en
marche l'accord en 18 jours on a fait
l'équivalent de ce que le précédent
gouvernement avait fait en 18 mois on va
terminer cette méthode avec l'image
d'une marcheuse mais n'est pas de votre
camp c'est la sénatrice écologiste
esther benbassa qu'on a vu à la
manifestation de samedi avec cette
pancarte et elle vous l'avez vu plus
plus de cannabis - de police qu'est-ce
que vous répondrez attaquants parce que
vous réagissez vous êtes contre toute
légalisation
ce que je n'ai pas compris si vous avez
dit plus je risque de grêle je ne sais
plus oui et non pas la russe non ben je
sais pas et elle est plutôt bon dans un
parti qui prône la légalisation pour moi
pour moi n'est plus bon enfant de lui
plus en tout cas si la question de
savoir si oui ou non il faut légaliser
le cannabis
moi je suis contre la légalisation du
cannabis je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut
lutter sans relâche contre les réseaux
il faut contrat vendanges
non je ne dis pas qu'elle se trompe je
dis qu'il ya un vrai il ya toujours eu
un débat le débat il il est légitime
je vous dis ma position d'accord
personnellement je suis contre la
légalisation je pense qu'en revanche il
faut lutter sans relâche contre les
réseaux et contraventions analysé lire
usage de stups pour faire en sorte que
ça ne reste pas impuni
merci merci à rebours des devoirs est
avec nous aujourd'hui merci à vous deux
bonsoir à tous et à très vite la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]